Let's get back to our Mount Shasta example. In this case, remember our null
hypothesis would be based on the population. So knowing which null hypothesis
to use, it can be tricky. You'll continue to keep building up an intuitive
sense of what the null hypothesis should be, depending on the situation and the
question you're asking. In our example, we now know what kind of success to
expect based on the null hypothesis. And we also know what kind of success the
guide company observed last year. And now we need to test how well these
obtained sample frequencies or proportions fit the population proportions or
our expected frequencies. This is called the kai squared goodness of fit test.
You might be wondering about the alternative hypothesis. The alternative
hypothesis is basically that the null hypothesis is not true. In this type of
test we really only need to use numbers for the null hypothesis. As usual with
the tests you've learned about, there's a test statistic. And it's symbolized
by kai squared. Before we get into the details of this test statistic, think
about it yourself. How would you statistically show that the observed frequency
is greater or less than the expected frequency? Would you subtract one from the
other? Would you add things? Multiply or divide things? I'm being very vague.
But before you move on to the next video, maybe pause and think about how you
would construct a statistic such that if the observed frequencies are very
different from the expected frequencies. We'd get one number that's bigger than
if the observed and expected frequencies were similar.